deuxième figure demi - on danse la haute
taille un ensemble de quadrille ou
danseurs et danseuses répondre aux
ordres d'un commandeur il n'y en a pas
dans cette salle pas d'orchestre on se
contente du 8 me de céder ils sont en
des pétitions deux fois par semaine en
majorité des retraités
il prépare un bal des changes prévu le 4
novembre tout en haut du mât en activité
gipa on n'a pas toujours le temps donc
la mettant depuis huit ans sur la
retraite donc voilà et comment ça va
très bien j'ai du mal g parce que je
suis timide et ça fait 22 ans que je
suis là donc là je suis bien et depuis
deux ans après j'ai lâché ça fait une
danse accommodements qui tire ses
origines de la colonisation accepté de
danser implique ne pas être trop
susceptible
d'où l'expression mens pas cadencés la
haute taille c'est pour mon pack ou
moins des morts brian a effectivement
qui se rebelle
justement qu'ils appliquent cet adage
mais bon on est obligé de s'y faire de
se mettre d'eux
daube et d'obéir au dîner moi je dors
chez what i'm alive 26 ans c'est souvent
parce que murray a laissé de la gomme
digeo souvent oui ils viennent pour
s'amuser se dépenser durant environ deux
heures
l'association qu'à rallier aux dames et
c'est de maintenir une tradition qui
trouvent difficilement écho auprès des
jeunes